right here says jose juan cerribus is
where his neighbor's holiday home once
stood
today all that's left is this pile of
rubble
it was destroyed in a devastating winter
storm last year
they've become more and more common
sariba says they show climate change is
increasingly endangering spain's ebro
delta
for years locals have demanded better
coastal protections
but their calls have fallen on deaf ears
the storms and authorities in action are
harming
something anything must be done
locals are growing desperate
extreme weather events and rising sea
water levels have eroded the coast
leaving little more than this strip of
land near the river delta
it is the last line of defense between
the sea
and the countless rice paddies that lie
in land
the spanish government wants to
nationalize over 800 hectares of
privately owned land to turn it into an
additional buffer zone
but the plan angers local rice farmers
cerribas fears he could lose half of his
crops
and it's not clear what sort of
compensation he would receive in return
most farmers are not only concerned
about financial losses though
this is emotional
in many cases rice fields have been
passed on for many generations
i worked very hard to get mine
the government's plan doesn't bode well
for the delta
in fact it will destroy the delta under
values
but not everyone opposes the
government's plan
environmentalists regard the delta as
one of europe's most important wetlands
over 300 bird species inhabit the region
sophia revise runs a private bird
sanctuary
she thinks there's no point in piling up
tons of sand or dumping wave breakers in
the sea as farmers are demanding
the predominant mentality was to exploit
nature to the fullest when practically
the entire delta was transformed into
rice fields
now it's time for change
but not everyone approves of this
scientists say natural solutions are
better suited to reducing the effects of
climate change
denying this is like denying covert
for a long time environmental groups
have been protesting against another
related problem
the abro river is carrying less and less
sediment into the delta
that's because dozens of dams further
upriver are keeping the mud back
and mud is what the delta is made of
at this rally demonstrators pour soil
into the river to highlight that without
natural sediments the delta will be at
even greater risk from climate change
is it's very important to restore the
river's ecological impact
otherwise it will be extremely difficult
to offset the effects of climate change
specifically the flooding and loss of
land
rice farmer sorry and his friends
meanwhile could not disagree more
they don't want to wait years for the
river to carry more sediments
instead they are expecting the
government to take immediate action
after all
other countries are already protecting
their coastlines they
we could say serious economic decline
for instance in the construction sector
that's allowed to happen
who will invest in her delta
locals are divided over how to deal with
the threat of climate change and the
eroding ebro delta
though it might be too late if they wait
until environmentalists farmers and the
government reach a consensus
the next winter storm
is always just around the corner